[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce iront
parler sport toute l'équipe de
l'émission vous souhaite une très belle
année à 2018 même si l'année change on
garde la même recette pour ce tout que
sportif il y aura comme d'habitude des
analyses des débats et des duels
acharnés entre les meilleurs experts des
yvelines sur le sport local aujourd'hui
ils sont cinq
autour de la table et je vous rassure
ils n'ont pas trop abusé pendant les
fêtes pour être dans les meilleures
conditions physiques
aujourd'hui présentation en musique on
commence à la droite musical est
toujours aussi radieuse en 2018 ça
pendant les vacances ça n'a pas réussi à
lâcher sa barre de pole dance son sport
de prédilection comme on a pu le voir
précédemment la soirée quelques images
qui sont passés à n'a pas pris un seul
gramme pour les fêtes de noël a toujours
très élégante notre ambassadrice de
charme
hélène de la grange est avec nous
bonjour hélène alors on est ravi de vous
retrouver en 2018
haegen boîte aussi bons amis je le
disais le fait on était sportive
oui oui j'ai pas réussi à 900 t de trois
jours j'ai continué à pratiquer vous
avez gardé la forme c'est ça on passe à
ma gauche musique c'est l'une des
légendes de cette émission à tel point
que j'ai pris rendez vous avec le
président de tv 78 pour lui demander
d'installer une statue de bronze de ce
chroniqueur devant le studio s'est
également demande de ses fans l'ancien
coach de rugby de paix dire j'en lis est
avec nous pendant une heure bonjour jean
vaujour vikhael comment allez-vous à
plein de formes
moi aussi je me suis résonné pendant les
fêtes impeccable j'ai passé un peu plus
de temps à table que sur les terrains de
sport mais tout va bien j'aurai pu
profiter
j'ai très bien profiter dans le sud
ouest on profite toujours un peu plus
bonne année quand même tout le monde
alors je vais essayer pour la statue en
bronze
dans le studio c'est pas gagné ça va
coûter cher monde repasse de l'autre
côté à musique qui nous vient tout droit
de versailles c'est un véritable accro
au sport rugby golf course à pied et
j'en passe c'est également un redoutable
chroniqueur il va ne va pas hésiter à
aller au duel terre sébastien chabal
aujourd'hui j'en suis sûr pierre
chevalier du club de rugby de versailles
est avec nous comment allez-vous pierre
fort bien meilleurs voeux à toutes et
tous est en pleine forme pour démarrer
cette dès l'année 2018 qu'est ce qu'on
peut vous souhaiter pour 2018 une baie
ryder cup à saint quentin en yvelines
était stationnaire
et puis plein de plein de beaux
événements sportifs ce sera en septembre
du 28 au 30 septembre au golf national
de saint quentin en yvelines près où
vous l'avez dit on repasse à gauche ce
musique c'est l'homme le plus brillant
du département un véritable cerveau
c'est un scientifique du sport local
nous avons pu exceptionnellement le
sortir de son laboratoire pour cette
émission
le professeur fenech andersen le
directeur sportif des templiers
d'elancourt est avec nous pour réussir
en parler sport bonjour frédéric bonjour
à tous bonne année alors qu'est ce qu'on
peut vous souhaiter à vous à du bonheur
de la réussite de la victoire la même
chose que tout le monde je pense dans le
département niveau sportif
voilà on vous raccompagne dans votre
laboratoire juste après l'émission
c'est gentil on termine par un petit
nouveau musique c'est un spécialiste du
football il l'a vu grandir des prodiges
du football français comme lassana
diarra qui lie à mbacké où jean kévin
augustin il a également créé un club de
foot
à plaisir le plaisir roi georges gomis
nous fait l'honneur de rejoindre
l'équipe il dit de si on va les sports
bonjour bonjour bonjour à tous georges
bomis mon mais écoutez je vous souhaite
une bonne année plein de joie et de
réussite et et de de commandes de santé
surtout voilà vous sentez vous pour
cette grande première sur ses pattes à
écouter un déjà c'est un grand plaisir
et avec tous les amis du sport et je
suis très heureux de pouvoir participer
à cette émission est bon pour une
première j'espère que je vais pas te
dire trop de bêtises on va passer
maintenant au programme de l'émission
aujourd'hui nous allons à parler de
cyclisme l'édition 2018 de paris-nice
passera pour la neuvième fois
consécutive dans les yvelines
nous évoquerons également la coupe de
france de basket avec la défaite à
l'ultime seconde du chesnay versailles
mais avant de développer ses coûts ses
coups de projecteurs ce coup de
projecteur sur la belle épopée de
houille en coupe de france
[Musique]
nous commençons donc par du football où
une équipe de r3 affronter ce samedi à 6
janvier le club de national une
concarneau en 32e de finale de la coupe
de france cinq divisions séparaient les
deux équipes avant le match le coach ne
se faisait guère d'illusion pardon on
joue une montagne voulait que pourquoi
voulait construire son risque rien mais
on part en part en part de loin
on est très loin de de concarneau qui
voulez je vous dise de plus soit pas se
mettre la pression
on est très loin de concarneau c'est une
grosse grosse équipe voulez que je vous
dise quoi de plus on se prépare on se
fait plaisir et on verra bien toute
façon nous on n'a rien à perdre ces
craintes se sont finalement confirmé le
jour du match les joueurs d'où se sont
inclinés 3 à 0 face au pensionnaire de
national une devant plus de 2000
spectateurs les yvelinois petit poucet
de la coupe de france ont totalement
raté leur début de match avec deux buts
encaissés dans les 15 premières minutes
de la rencontre on écoute la réaction
des joueurs après le match
déçue déçue de déçus de la philosophie
du match parce qu'on première mi temps
je pense qu'on les a trop respectés et
après en deuxième on a été plus haut on
a montré qu'on avait un peu de qualité
mais bon c'est le football est comme ça
les yvelinois pourront se consoler en
regardant un match du psg depuis le parc
des princes les joueurs ont été invités
par le président du paris saint germain
à venir assister à une rencontre la
question sur ce thème se souviendra-t-on
de ce parcours de houille en coupe de
france
oui ou non ont été partagés pour fredrik
andersson gens non oui pour george
george pour votre votre premier duel
allez-y comment c est ce qu on se
souviendra du parcours de rouille en
coupe de france puis je pense que oui
étant donné leur niveau
leur niveau actuel dans les yvelines
s'est pas souvent arrivé qu'un club
d'une si basse échelle depuis son
arrivée en 32e de finale de la coupe de
france
bon il ne s'est pas tu le veux et où il
y adeux comme en 2d que ce joueur
professionnel misère par toufik que je
connaissais qui joua comment à en
national niveau national national hull
moi je tiens quand même à féliciter ces
garçons là et j'espère que le club et
les yvelinois peuvent garder aussi en
mémoire c'est sait comment cet exploit
parce que pour moi c'est un exploit même
s'ils ont perdu ils ont perdu alors ils
ont perdu avec les armes est bon je
pense que la ville d'où y aider les
jeunes footballeurs de douilles
les dirigeants les yvelinois bas ils
peuvent dire que voilà où ils ont ils
ont fait un sacré un sacré exploit pour
moi c'est un exploit
voilà genre qu'est ce que vous répondez
à charge alors pour moi
pour moi ce n'est pas un exploit
l'exploit on est équivoque qu'il bat
concarneau en 32e avec cinq divisions
d'écart la sauvette un exploit mais là
la logique du sport a été respectée et
les cinq divisions d'écart alors bon on
a tenu et c'est le capitaine je sais pas
si c'est le capitaine et qu'elle veut
c'est le capitaine qui a dit qu il
dézone trop respecté je sais pas si les
zones trop respectés je pense qu'ils
sont ils sont pas rentrés dans le match
ils étaient peut-être un petit peu
fébrile malgré le fait qu'ils disent
qu'ils n'avaient rien à perdre ils
avaient tout à gagner sur tout et je
pense que le hir à bord des bus de
marque ça leur coûte de but
dans les quinze mairie 15 premières
minutes et dans tous les sports c'est
compliqué de renverser la vapeur
surtout avec avec cette différence de
niveau où ils ont dû après tombés sur
une équipe qui a dû gérer certainement
son match et qui en a remis un contre ou
une chose comme ça mais pour moi la
logique a été respectée donc l'exploit
n'est pas la logique également pour vous
pierre chevalier
oui je sais le mot que j'avais j'avais
écrit jean l'a rappelé je trouve que la
coupe de france l'ea fois mais la fois
magique et à la fois c'est injuste on en
a parlé en fin d'année lorsque
l'événement monter qu'on avait où il
qualifié pour jouer concarneau avec cinq
divisions d'écart c'était fantastique et
ça promettait déjà un beau un beau
trajet là malheureusement avec un 3 0
la logique est respectée et là où je
pense pas que ça sera ça sera mémorable
même si c'est très fréquent de voir un
club des yvelines à ce niveau là c'est
que la chute est encore plus terrible à
dire car on en parle beaucoup avant irak
cette marche là ils prennent 3 0 contre
à mieux classés la logique est respectée
on en parlera peut-être un peu moins
dans l'histoire dans l'histoire du jeu
pour des îles hélène ils ont quand même
été en une de l'équipe
samedi juste avant la rencontre pour un
club local très rare c'est voilà c'est
cette petite montée et le fait qu'il y
ait eu cette possibilité c'est vraiment
un encouragement ccc des possibilités
mais comme on le disait il ya vraiment
trop d'écart donc oui l'art descente a
été difficile je pense qu'ils ont
vraiment espérer ils sont dit on y va on
y va mais ils sont retrouvés un peu en
face d'eux
deux des décalages de niveau est un peu
face à finalement dans cette logique
encore voilà c'est ça c'est il ya encore
beaucoup de travail pour essayer de
faire diminuer un peu cet écart là c'est
trop statut freda corner scène de petit
poucet de la compétition sur ces 32e de
finale finalement ça a tiré toutes les
caméras de france sur eux on va s'en
souvenir forcément bas au moins ça
marquera déjà l'histoire du club et puis
ça montrera aux clubs alentours aussi
que c'est possible que aussi ils ont
peut-être une chance d'aller d'aller
aussi loin et je pense que de ce point
de vue là ça peut être mais moi après
d'un point de vue du football français
sa part marqué l'histoire avec un grand
h c'est pas ils ont perdu face une
équipe était beaucoup plus forte que
comme ça a été déjà dit avant la logique
sportive a été respectée
donc ça dépend de quel point de vue on
se place par rapport par rapport au club
je pense que ça restera un bon souvenir
surtout pour les joueurs donc ça rassure
un événement mémorable pour eux au
niveau du département peut-être encore
quelques années on en parlera en bo1
rappelez vous où ils ont été capables
d'aller jusqu'en 32e de finale et c'est
à vous est peut-être une chance joue
aussi d'y arriver mais au delà au delà
des limites du département c'est très
peu probable qu'on s'en souvienne plus
que ça pour la petite info où il ya déjà
réussi à atteindre les seizièmes de
finale en 1940
à l'époque il y avait deux coupes de
france celle de la zone libre et celle
de la zone occupée est oui avait perdu 2
0 contre reims c'est le meilleur
résultat du club
sinon dans l'ère moderne c'est le
meilleur résultat ces trois années
finalement donc c'est bashasha pour eux
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment une belle
performance surtout vous étant donné
leurs moyens et le niveau auquel les
évaluer il évolue et après au delà de ça
comme on l'a déjà dit c'est la loi du
sport 1
le plus fort gagne ça restera ça restera
gravé dans l'histoire du club
ça c'est sûr
cette performance mais pas après ça ne
traversera pas non ça n'ira pas plus
loin
d'accord vous étiez opposé mais
maintenant vous êtes d'accord
je suis d'accord je suis d'accord c'est
d'accord d'accord et donc il ya et il ya
une ambiance incroyable vraiment autour
de ce match a eu deux mille supporters
au stade ça aussi ça va marquer
l'histoire d'une ville oui deux mille
2000 personnes au stade je pense que la
plupart les uns des jeunes du club
comment les des anciens on devait bien
fier de mes garçons qui étaient sur le
terrain
je pense aussi que derrière ça va ça va
leur donner une belle dynamique pour
pouvoir recruter et puis avoir des
licenciés franck blanc quel type que je
connais parce qu'on a joué à verser
ensemble l'entraîneur de l'équipe
l'entraîneur de l'équipe bon qui est
inquiet un garçon assez rigoureux qui s
est un garçon assez rigoureuse parce que
lui il va s'appuyer sur ça pour faire
grandir le club mais bon je pense pas
qu'il va s'enflammer
moi je dirais qu'ils ont un grand bravo
à ce club
et puis je suis je suis vraiment fier de
ce qu'ils ont fait je suis très heureux
de 2 2 du match qu'ils ont donnée aussi
parce que hein quand on voit les l'ailé
malgré la déception il
ils ont reconnu que l'équipe était
supérieur et je pense que même si on a
perdu
même si on a perdu un match même si on
savait que l'adversaire est supérieur
mal si on rêverait pas l'exploit quand
on a tous les ingrédients derrière moi
je pense prendre perdre 3-0 contre
concarneau qui est un très bon club de
national nationale 2 la chine appelle
une une
cinq divisions nationales une île sont
exacts nationale pardon donc concarneau
perdre contre concarneau ça reste quand
même
logique certes mais vu vu s'occupera en
tirer de ce match là moi je pense que
pour eux basse et c'est bénéfique
c'est bénéfique c'est quelque chose de
bénéfique pour le club nous on continue
à parler à de la coupe de france mais
cette fois ci en basket dans le chaudron
de remilly le chesnay versailles qui
évolue au niveau 1 régional invaincu
depuis le début de la saison n'a pas
réussi à renverser les espoirs de proa
de châlons reims en 32e de finale les
yvelinois se sont inclinés à la dernière
seconde 83 à 80 dans une fin de match à
suspense
ils ont encaissé le dernier panier à la
toute dernière seconde on écoute les
réactions à la fin du match au micro de
nicolas donc ça fait mal parce que
j'aurais préféré perdre de 10,15 points
plutôt que comme ça sur un dernier tir
vous savez c'est toujours embêtant de
perdre les deux équipes sont vraiment
venu pour jouer cette équipe c'est une
bonne et jeune équipe elle est bien
entraîné il était vraiment préparé pour
gagner la question sur ce thème faut-il
avoir des regrets après cette rencontre
vous votez oui ou non oui oui à vous est
unanime
vous êtes 5 en plateau vous êtes tous
d'accord à la personne
à l'ats le professeur fait les camps
personnes on va des records n'ont pas de
regrets on se retrouve un peu dans le
cas de figure précédent et puis sont pas
passés loin de l'exploit et c'est vrai
que comme utilisé dans l'interview
si ça avait été de 10 15 20 points il
aurait pas eu aurait pas eu photo donc
les aurais pas pu s'accrocher à l'espoir
d'avoir pu créer l'espoir l'exploit que
là ils perdent de pas grand chose et
c'est vrai qu'on peut nourrir des
regrets de ce point de vue là se dire
qu'on est on n'est pas passé loin de
l'exploit mais justement bas tout est
dans la phrase c'est un exploit donc ça
ça reste difficile à réaliser donc avoir
des regrets pas de regret ça quand on
est un compétiteur on a toujours des
regrets face à face à une défaite
surtout quand elle est aussi faible mais
bon c'est la loi est juste pas encore
une fois et la logique a été
malheureusement respecter pour le club
du chesnay versailles
pierre c'est le problème du money time
c'est pour ça doit être ça aussi le les
différences d'expérience ils partent
avec un certain nombre de points de
retard et au final ils perdent sur un
dernier panier à l'ultime ultimes
minutes 10 secondes c'est là c'est là où
évidemment ils ont touché vraiment d'eau
proches une victoire une victoire de
prestige donc modérée des regrets
légitimes au vu du match qui a l'air de
s'être déroulé genre qui a raison qui a
tort plus du côté de pierre ducout si
oui je suis votre du pire plutôt parce
que c'est une affaire de sport un public
nombreux tout a été dit parce que tout a
été dit on est dans le même cas de
figure que le sujet juste avant au
niveau du football
voilà il y avait il y avait l'expérience
d'un côté mon avis sur cette main cette
gestion de fin de match où l'expérience
a parlé parce que je crois qu'ils ont
commencé avec 21 points dallas ce
rapport à leur niveau oui par rapport à
l'an niveau c'est finalement ils ont été
rattrapés assez rapidement et à il avait
un écart de plus 8 à 2 minutes 30 de la
fin
oui mais c'est en faveur du chesnay
versailles oui mais le basket c'est ça
le basket à deux minutes de la fin et
c'est long deux minutes en basket c'est
très très long très très long
hélas
c'est l'expérience qui a parlé tout
simplement ce qu'ils ont pas mal résisté
tout au long du match il y avait
vraiment et un café chaud résumé 35 22
en faveur du chesnay versailles dans le
premier quart temps 46 47 au deuxième
64 63 au troisième et 80 83 forcément
une troisième mission catholique au
premier quart temps ils ont ils ont pris
22 14
c'est ça les gens pris 22 14 depuis deux
matches alors oui non mais c'est vrai
parce que donc je passe de l'équipe
adverse quand même a fait une gestion de
match ils ont rattrapé le retard
rapidement pour après faire un match
la gestion un match normal de basket
avec l'expérience qui qui va avec le
niveau le regret il est plutôt là
justement il est plutôt fort parce qu'on
est sur quelque chose de sûre un score
égal à la fin et que se joue à la sage
au délire la dernière seconde dernière
minute parce que c'est le basket se joue
à la dernière seconde
il ya là il ya là tous les dumas et
chaoui plaisant mais sûrement la
sensation d'avoir gâché du temps gâché
dernière minute gâché le début en fait
le danish procès plus le match s'est
joué au début si la cisa et moins perdu
au début il y aurait il aurait conservé
un écart qui aurait peut-être permis que
ça se termine pas comme ça finalement
c'est dans cette gestion ont pu parler
du début c'est ça ou à mon avis c'est un
peu amer george où et comme le basket
mais on sait que c'est un sport encore
plus si le banc moi je pense que le banc
il doit jouer à fond parce qu'elle passe
que et en étant donné que chalon avec un
niveau supérieur le banc devait être
supérieur aussi pour les rotations et la
réserve tout simplement d'une équipe
professionnelle
donc le justement le pont il y est pour
quelque chose dans mon avis le godet
times grandissent dans le money time
si vous avez vous joueurs qui sont vos
meilleurs joueurs qui ont des fautes ils
peuvent - défendre vous avez des déchets
des aides
vous avez des joueurs c'est qu'ils ont
des meilleurs shooteurs
étant donné que leur palette est plus
grande au niveau il avait notamment un
joueur de haut niveau qui s'appelle
rambaud membre de l'équipe de france
jean baud il était très bas membre de
l'équipe de france u19 et joueurs de
l'effectif de proie justement de
l'équipe une
moi je pense que le bon 1 dans ce sport
là il y est pour beaucoup
lyon on sait qu il a marqué deux points
non je n'ai pas regardé là je sais que
le côté versailles c'est sylvester
morgan qu'on a entendu une interview qui
réunit les meilleurs marqueurs voilà
avec 15 points qu'on avait voilà on
avait déjà débattu sur lui sur son
arrivée quand il est arrivé au chesnay
versailles
donc pour vous georges c'est le banc
café ak fait la différence
oui à ce niveau là au basket c'est
souvent le banc qui fait la différence
qui les fautes les rotations les quais
et comment comment défendre parce que
quand on est des fautes on peut pas pas
défendre de la même manière que contient
pas de faute si on a des joueurs d'égal
niveau sur le banc je pense qu'à la fin
c'est souvent le cas vous n'en doute
alors ils étaient invaincus jusqu'à
présent le chesnay-versailles ce qu'on
pensait ça peut casser leur dynamique
faire des corners salon moi je pense que
le match était tellement exceptionnel
qu'au final ils vont peut-être le mettre
entre parenthèses l'eau mettront un peu
de côté retourner
leur quotidien de performer chaque
week-end se remettre dans leur
championnat
parce que la saison n'est pas terminée
là encore jeune j'ai un championnat
c'est long et on n'est qu'en janvier
donc il reste plusieurs mois de
compétition encore je pense qu'ils
auront temps de s'en remettre et puis
ils ont bien vu qu'ils avaient un bon
niveau qu'un que pour leurs résultats
qu'ils ont obtenus sur ce match là donc
on peut regarder bien sûr il ya la
déception d'avoir perdu mais il ya aussi
l'encouragement de savoir qu'on est
quand même un bon niveau de basket ball
et qu'on peut jouer des coudes avec des
équipes mieux classées
c'est dire que quand ils vont tourner en
championnat contre des équipes moins
bien classées je pense qu'ils ont la
confiance de leur côté et ça peut ça
peut vraiment les aider à finir fort
cette saison
pierre chevalier vous pensez qu'ils ont
accumulé de l'expérience sur ce match
indéniablement c'est à dire que la même
avec des points d'avance perdre à la
dernière seconde contre une équipe mieux
classée
de toute façon la sueur des sur des
matches comme ça un petit peu des
matches éliminatoires on acquiert
clairement de l'été de l'expérience
c'est un peu le parallèle qu'on peut
faire avec le football également est
clairement sa lancée en janvier là en
début de ce2 rendant en début d'année ça
va leur servir pour les les derniers
mois de la saison - ils sont où ils ont
vu des médias meilleur des joueurs qui
gère mieux le banc et les rotations
oui ça leur servira ça sera moins la fin
sur ce thème après le basket nous allons
passer un autre sport collectif longue
balle
on ouvre donc une page de handball
féminin le club de montigny le
bretonneux a connu une première partie
de saison à mitiger lésigny monteyne
sont classés à la dernière place du
championnat de nationale 2 alors que
l'équipe viser la montée au mois de
septembre pire à nous à l'heure actuelle
aucune victoire à leur actif depuis
septembre mais le président du club
christophe reading croit toujours que le
club peut réaliser une romande tada on
les écoute et un effet encore jusqu'à la
fin de saison on est parti sur un groupe
reconstitué pour pour partie et on a
subi en fait quelques blessures chez
chez certaines joueuses cadres qui a
impacté malheureusement les résultats
l'esprit de groupe les entraînements
donc par rapport à ça donc on était un
petit peu en difficulté dès à présent
nous avons une reprise des entraînements
est qui et qui s'effectue en fait ce
soir avec un premier match ce week-end
ou contre aubervilliers où on escompte
en fait que ça ça revient comme l'année
dernière une rue montana pourquoi pas
mais en tout cas on l'espère la remonte
à da il y croit en tout cas le président
de l'as continuant de balle la question
sur ce thème est ce que vous y croyez
vous à s'être montana oui ou non non oui
partager encore on fait un petit duel
entre frédéric et vous et là je pense
que c'est bien de l'espérer de
travailler en ce sens etc
mais là je pense que ça c'est difficile
d'avoir plusieurs années de suite avoir
un déclassement comme ça de devoir
prouver remonter c'est fatigant et c'est
beaucoup de travail à fournir beaucoup
de
beaucoup de il ya beaucoup à fournir et
je pense que ça risque d'être difficile
vraiment après on leur souhaite c'est ce
qu'on dit toujours là - ça sent vraiment
dernière avec juste 9.9 au classement on
a quand même un peu de marge mais bon
voilà la saison n'est pas finie mais
c'est zéro victoire alors là ça serait
bien qu'elle gagne un match que salir
booste un peu mais c'est moi ça me
paraît un peu difficile comme ça c'est
compliqué à moins qu'ils aient vraiment
un
un boost d'un coup comme ça est vraiment
une prise de conscience et un gros
travail mais ça me paraît ça me paraît
un peu difficile pour elle
fred a craint personne deuxième duel
pour vous aujourd'hui ça dépend jusqu'où
on voit la remonte à la cua le dire est
qu'elles vont finir au top de la
division ça risque d'être compromis
parce que déjà premiers sons à 24 points
c'est à dire que 15 points de retard il
on prend qu'organise hong kong a gagné
un seul match
les vois un match nul à la première
journée contre le paris saint germain
mais les voir arriver jusqu'en haut du
classement en six mois alors que pendant
six mois elles ont pas réussi à
remporter un match ça risque d'être
compliqué après ce qu'elles peuvent
sortir de la zone rouge et bien se
classer en fin de championnat ça reste
jouable
on voit que mathématiquement elles sont
pas si loin que ça elles peuvent revenir
à 14,15 points ça fait que 5 6 points de
retard elles peuvent elles peuvent sur
six mois ya sept ans pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir se remettre dans une dynamique
de victoire mais c'est vrai que briser
une dynamique de défaite c'est déjà
compliqué en soi
donc de là à remonter sur les premières
marches du puits du classement ça risque
d'être vraiment très compliqué genre qui
a raison qui a tort vous êtes avec
hélène plutôt avec hammerson
non mais les deux ont raison mais
pendant ce pas là je ferais tu si
l'enfant si la non mais c'est pas ça
mais pour moi alors
ils ont quand même pas gagné un seul
match alors là ça commence à devenir
compliqué parce que on a
et frédéric l'a dit un petit peu aussi
il ya quand même la spirale de la
défaite
et c'est très compliqué de sortir de
cette spirale de défaites
effectivement il faudrait un match
engagé pour pouvoir renverser la vapeur
mais il ya le doute qui s'installe à
quand une équipe perd et ne fait que
perdre le doute s'installe sportivement
il est très très compliqué beaucoup plus
compliqué nous remercier le rappeur
quand on perd que continuer à gagner
parce que la spirale de la victoire on
est beaucoup plus c'est l'état d'esprit
est beaucoup plus positif mais là c'est
très difficile et pour moi alors
mathématiquement neuf poèmes 24 points
pour moi c'est impossible mais même déjà
juste juste la vanne dernier est à
quatre points sur mathématiquement rien
n'est fait mais quand même être
compliqué ça va être compliqué quoi et
moi pour moi il faut inverser cette
spirale de défaites
pierre avait réussi à accomplir une
remonte à la saison passée vous pensez
qu'il peut lire il peut y avoir la même
dynamique
cette saison ses saisons peuvent se
ressembler en cette période de voeux
c'est ce que je leur souhaite c'est pour
compléter ce kangoo ce qu'on dit mais
mes petits camarades je pense que c'est
le c'est une affaire une recherche de
déclic c'est un match qui va taire pour
une pour x raisons pencher la balance et
changer changer un petit peu l'attitude
passée d'une spirale de défaites à je
pense pas il spirale de victoires malgré
tout parce qu'elles sont assez malins
mal en point mais au moins briser une
brise et une une série de deux défaites
et puis remonter un petit peu mais comme
disait fred là ce stade de la saison
viser le top 5 voire la montée là ça
serait vraiment au delà de l'art
montador une un exploit assez
remarquable on leur souhaite malgré tout
georges vous pensez pas qu'il faut un
électrochoc
l'entraîneur de niche lui un an et demi
peut-être que son message ne passe plus
même si là encore la confiance du
président alors actuellement il faut
changer pour des décisions et enfin de
telles décisions pour vraiment dire s'il
faut changer ou faute à l'intérieur du
club
il faut vivre avec avec les gens mais un
bon étant donné que le coach l'avait
déjà fait l'année dernière
moi je pense que bon comme ses camarades
il ya trop d'écarts quand on est dans
une spirale de défaite on ne commet il
faut déjà réapprendre à gagner
il faudrait reprendre à gagner enlevez
le coach je ne sais pas parce que un le
derrière il peut y avoir aussi des dd
mécontenter bon ce stade de la saison il
reste pas beaucoup de matches c'est pas
si enfin je peux pas dire exactement si
ça sort ça aura un effet bénéfique
maintenant si les filles sont encore
mobilisés avec le coach que son discours
y parce que 1 que comment les matchs se
sont assez bien construit qui ne
prennent pas trop deux taules bas je
pense que ils peuvent accrocher le
maintien
un maintien ils peuvent l'accroché voilà
ils peuvent encore chez moi je suis dit
c'est pas possible
non la montée je peux enfin là c'est
l'année samira qu'il faut c'est ce
qu'ils ont réalisé sur le sapin il faut
100 % de victoires
en deuxième partie de saison moi je le
reçois est un du fond du coeur je leur
souhaite du fond du coeur mais là les il
faut dire qu'on a des adversaires en fin
de journée des adversaires en face et
les adversaires ils y gagnent galligan
ils sont dans une dynamique
donc c'est pas parce que vous vous allez
vous mettre à gagner que les camps se
met à perdre
voilà épuisant la gestion ils ont la
gestion de la saison maintenant quand
vous allez rencontrer une équipe telle
que mal classés vous allez vous savez
pertinemment pertinemment pertinemment
savoir excusez moi que tu as un moment
ou un autre comme ils sont mal classés
ils vont venir et donc à partir du
moment qu'ils vont dire votre plan de
bataille pour gagner le match
il est déjà presque il est déjà presque
comment
ficelez donc une équipe qui est dans une
dynamique de défaite est aussi dans une
dynamique d'erreurs et la moindre erreur
du coup de chair et la même erreur lui
coûte cher et les imperfections les
commandes et les les impatiences les en
patience parce que c'est souvent des
cantos est né là bas même quand ça
marche bien
eh ben on est impatient de serre marche
mal quand on est dernier quand ça marche
bien on n'est en fait qu'un patient est
cantonné dernier ben on est encore un
peu plus impatients et le fait de voir
les autres devant même si vous menez un
vous mener au score
eh bien il vous pouvez perdre le match
parce que vous pouvez être impatient
alors qu'une équipe
les cinq premiers et ils ont cette
sérénité là il joue pas avec le couteau
à la gorge et derrière quand ils
arrivent quand ils arrivent au stade
dans leur plan de bataille contre les
derniers ils le connaissent en tout cas
je vois que le sujet vous tient à coeur
vous avez pas arrêter de taper à ce
matin cependant il faut dire aussi que
votre réponse les scores qu'ils ont pu
et occasion de lui faire un si elles ont
vraiment perdu beaucoup normalement
c'était deux trois quatre buts voilà
bondi sur vingt deux petites défaites ça
peut peut-être éventuellement chez
mercer on passe un nouveau thème du
cyclisme à présent dans notre deuxième
coup de projecteur le parcours officiel
du paris nice 2018 a été dévoilée ce
mardi 9 janvier à versailles par les
organisateurs comme chaque année depuis
neuf ans le peloton s'élancera le
dimanche 4 mars depuis les yvelines
après bois d'arcy en 2017 c'est au tour
de chatou d'être ville départ du paris
nice le 4 mars prochain donc le peloton
s'élancera pour un départ fictif de
l'île des impressionnistes avant un
départ réel à four que les cyclistes
passeront ensuite par ville promet
villiers saint frédéric avant de
s'engouffrer dans la vallée de chevreuse
on écoute le directeur de course de
paris nice à françois lemarchand
on va les chercher à coups de boules et
les trous on va aller chercher la coupe
de châteaufort mais côté stèle jacques
anquetil donc ça parle aussi des mots
c'était sont des endroits qui parle et
un retour sur saint quentin en yvelines
bois d'arcy et après on sûr du
département
à la celle saint cloud au total le
premier jour une étape de 135 km sera
proposé aux coureurs avec une arrivée à
meudon le lendemain le peloton prendra
le départ de la deuxième étape depuis le
village d'or sont ville une commune de
moins de 400 habitants située dans les
environs de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
une ville intéressante selon thomas
voeckler le nouvel ambassadeur du paris
nice
moi je trouve ça bien parce que le vélo
c'est pas que le tour de france des
épreuves comme paris nice ça permet
aussi à des communes qui n'ont peut-être
pas toujours les moyens d'accueillir le
tour de france abat d'avoir une épreuve
cycliste de redon avec des coureurs de
renom et et puis pas faire plaisir à
tout le monde aux habitants aux gamins
des écoles pas loin ou quoi c'est bien
après avoir entendu toutes ces réactions
la question sur ce thème le paris-nice
doit-il rester dans les yvelines je vous
rappelle qu'un partenariat est signé
encore pendant trois ans avec le
département oui oui vous êtes tous
unanimes
fenech reversât moi je pense que dès
qu'il ya un événement d'envergure
nationale voire internationale pouvoir
était impliqué dedans et et pouvoir
rayonner à travers bénéficier un peu des
projecteurs que dont peut bénéficier
l'événement c'est toujours un plus
surtout placer un départ fictif entre
guillemets c'est juste pour marquer le
début de l'épreuve l'avantagent de ce
genre de d'étape c'est surtout qu'on a
le temps de voir les couleurs passées
c'est vrai que pour le public c'est
toujours sympa que quand on gagne et une
étape du tour de france ça va à 200 à
l'heure une passe au bout de dix minutes
s'est terminée donc c'est une bonne idée
pour vous ce départ fictif juge bien sûr
surtout que c'est un sport qui marche
bien dans les yvelines et on entend
souvent et je pense que il faut
continuer à promouvoir par le biais du
doigt par le plus élevé du vélodrome et
ce genre d'événement de a essayé de
faire d'engranger plus de pratiquants et
c'est développer la pratique sportive
quelle qu'elle soit c'est toujours
toujours bénéfique surtout que c'est un
sport accessible à tous et tout le monde
sait faire du vélo
je pense que faut bénéficier de tous et
de tous ses aspects qui se complète
facilement hélène ou pensais pas il faut
changer département aller vers les
hauts-de-seine même si là ça passe par
les hauts-de-seine les sols est contente
oui j'aime bien vu qu'on ça ferait
plaisir à yann s'il était là
consultant cyclisme qui devait venir
mais qui n'est pas vous alors
heureusement sur cette non moi j'aime
bien ce qui se passe voilà dans le
département même si c'est que le départ
voilà qui a que c'est vraiment juste
départ fictif sais c'est pas grave comme
disait frédéric il ya tout un coup de
projecteur fait c'est le début c'est
hyper important c'est le regard qu'on a
dès le début de la course donc je
n'aimerais pas que ça change votre
convaincu par les événements aussi
pierre chevalier complètement convaincu
pour y vivre et pratiquer du sport je
sais que les yvelines camy les frais de
compte énormément de cyclistes c'est pas
mon cas mais j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de
d'amis et de connaissances qui roulent
beaucoup dans les yvelines et notamment
en vallée de chevreuse donc c'est au
moins au moins une très bonne chose car
on aura sera pas voilà donc c'est c'est
être au contact des sites liste des
villes qui sont très nombreux et qui
roulent justement tous les dimanches
tous les samedis là où ils vont passer
les coureurs
et puis deux autres dans un deuxième
temps c'est une exposition qui est
toujours qui est toujours très très
impressionnante alors peut-être un grand
un peu inférieur à celui du tour de
france d'une ville établira et parme est
exactement le moment de télévision que
sur un tour de france à la télévision m
la compétition c'est encore mieux pour
les yvelines alors qu'avant c'était 167
comparé aux 198 tour de france ces
années c'est un espèce une espèce de
reportages vivons qui part qui part de
chatou mais mon fictifs qui passe par
fourqueux et qui finit dans une petite
ville des yvelines
et ça pendant les périodes on finit à
meudon et après ils repassent le
lendemain arbres sont bizarres et c'est
une centaine une centaine de kilomètres
à travers les divines pour montrer les
beautés du département et de ses petits
trous qu'il est agréable de fait
le cycle est alors l'année dernière il
ya eu beaucoup de spectacle dans les
yvelines pour la première étape au
départ de bois d'arcy avec la victoire
d'arnaud démare au sprint une course qui
a beaucoup plu à christian prudhomme le
directeur d'amaury sport organisation
pour lui c'était la meilleure course de
ces vingt dernières années on écoute
c'était une idée absolument magnifique
alors c'était dur aussi aux conditions
atmosphériques bien sûr c'était une
étape folle la pluie le vent les
bordures et savait donner une étape est
insolente qui s'était terminé par un
doublé français les électeurs d'arnaud
démare devant julian alaphilippe donc
c'était c'était plutôt pas mal sur miss
il peut y avoir du spectacle dans les
yvelines
oui forcément les lapins cuisse il a
vécu l'an dernier déjà
non mais ce qu'il ya de très très bien
ça je crois que c'est voeckler qu'il a
dit ça permet aussi à des add
municipalité de pouvoir prétendre à
participer une grande classique pas
participé pardon organisé une grande
classique comme le paris nice et qui est
quand même voilà petit que sitôt ville à
l'image hors centre-ville c'est tout
petit tout petit village c'est ce que
vous avez dit tout peut servir ce en
évitant à tout petit village bien ça
leur permet d'organiser un départ d'une
étape du grand classique comme celle de
paris nice mais c'est très très bien
c'est moi je dis que c'est
il n'y a pas que le tour de france et
c'est très très bien parce que ça montre
on connaît on connaît le prix en fait on
connait oui ça a été dit le prix pour
organiser une étape du tour de france
le départ ou une arrivée c'est
exorbitant
donc ça permet aussi qu'être d'être
sacrément chaput voilà un petit peu plus
abordable et ça permet vu qu'elle est là
quasiment les mêmes aux coureurs de
remplir les mêmes fonctions que peut
remplir de tournon phrase on va écouter
justement les habitants d'orson ville
qui était ravie tout simplement
d'accueillir la compétition
oui je suis contente
je suis pas trop si tu lis moi mais mon
conjoint je suis donc on va sûrement
aller voir les les coureurs ça va
peut-être dynamiser un peu le village
quoi là parce que c'est un petit peu
calme quoi découvrir un peu aux gens du
village dans son île georges wimax en
réalité c'est une
c'est une fois pour moi un déjà les
aiguines sait qu'il tient enfin c'est
une terre c'est une terre du vélo quand
vous vous promenez enfin vous roulez
vous vous promenez dans la vallée de
chevreuse tout le monde en pierres vers
dampierre on tous les sons là ils sont
là et et comment même le tour de france
dans son tracé passe pas aussi par les
yvelines mais est d'avoir une course de
ce type dans les yvelines comme une
école l'odyssée c'est bénéfique faut pas
s'en priver
craint il faut pas s'en priver est-ce
que déjà c'est si ces accidents de
cyclisme s'est incliné accessible à tout
le monde c'est accessible à tout le
monde ça permet ça permet aussi de
commandes aux gens d'être proche
y'a pas de ya pas deux il ya moins de il
ya plus de proximité que d'autres sports
est bon pour les beautés de notre de
notre département parce qu'on a un super
département avec avait aussi qui permet
aussi de pouvoir organiser des courses
puisqu'il ya des il ya des vallées il ya
on a tous dans les yvelines
on a la beauté et puis ça nous permet
aussi de montrer nos usines entre les
yvelines notre département à travers
plusieurs pays ce qui va ramener aussi
des touristes et de ce type de course il
ya beaucoup de coureurs français qui
participe donc un cocorico qui veut
vivre le paris-nice au logis et le paris
nice restera dans les yvelines jusqu'en
après notre page coup de projecteur
place à notre focus du jour dans notre
focus on continue à parler de cyclisme
il n'y aura pas de nouveau record pour
le super centenaires robert marchand le
sportif de 106 ans qui avait réalisé en
2010 7 22 points 5 km en 1h au vélotour
national de saint quentin en yvelines
est officiellement à la retraite le
sportif d'un mètre cinquante à annoncer
je cite qu'il avait la tension qui
déconnait pourquoi pourtant de l'année
dernière il avait l'air d'en avoir
encore sous la
nous avions eu sa réaction juste après
son record j'ai prévu lundi dernier les
vieilles 1 minute et jarret et déboguer
publie justement les sacs j'attendais
mais j'ai pas vu c'est la question à sur
ce thème robert marchand est il encore
des choses à prouver
oui à les activités à la racine entre
pierre et jean pierre lui celui ci pour
uc pour justement m'opposer l'essai je
trouve ça hyper frais un centenaire
comme ça il va y en avoir de plus en
plus dans les années à venir
cent cinq ans à vélo quelque chose à
prouver
a priori il aurait pu il aurait pu faire
un record à 106 ans puisse arrêter
s'inscrire encore un peu plus dès lors
il avait prévu de faire un record à 107
ans voilà donc censé temps il aurait été
leader était encore temps
les analystes voient dans l'histoire et
c'est c'est absolument fantastique et
rassurant sur sur les bénéfices de la
pratique sportive quelle qu'elle soit
j'ai mis les phrases qu'il a évoqué
quand on lui a dit mais quelle est votre
recette il est dit j'ai usé de tous mais
abusé de rien et c'est super c'est super
instructif de savoir qu'un qu'un
bonhomme comme sa 107 106 est encore là
a fait six records a fait ses tours à
vélo
encore une fois le vélo c'est pas mon
sport de prédilection mais là c'est
absolument remarquable
voir un centenaire comme ça qu'il aurait
pu peut-être aller pousser jusqu'à 107
ans et ce qu'il pourrait dire genre et
comme nous pas d'abus ont cependant et
fait surtout pendant les fêtes
donc là on peut espérer faire les mêmes
performances
il a plus rien à prouver heureusement
qu'il a pu être prouvée 5 6 ans
il a la sagesse aussi le pouvoir de
s'arrêter parce que le corps a des
limites et surtout à cet âge là et je
pense que médicalement on a dû lui dire
non là il faut arrêter parce qu'il faut
commencer à penser pour la vie des
anecdotes le centenaire n'a pris qu'un
seul médicament par jour pour sa tension
ou qui déconnait comme ils disaient
ouais et il commet il commence seulement
à avoir des rhumatismes
oui mais c'est sûr que bon là c'est une
exception c'est une belle explique cyril
une belle exception on dirait mais
abandonné il faut quand même être être
sérieux il est il est raisonnable
surtout et
est ce qu'il a déjà fait c'est énorme
sportivement et ne pas en rajouter je
pense que vous me raccrocher le vélo
mais un
pour tout ce qui est grande course
record et c'est évidemment qui à mon
avis va se garder des petites sorties
des petites choses comme ça c'est c'est
la retraite voilà c'est sa retraite mais
uniquement pour les concours voilà on va
passer maintenant notre rubrique débats
on observe le même phénomène tous les
ans nouvelle année rime souvent avec
résolution et faire plus de sport figure
en tête de liste 4 français sur 10
devraient pousser les portes d'une salle
de fitness dès les premiers jours de
janvier
une fois le 31 décembre passé les salles
de sport enregistre deux à trois fois
plus d'inscriptions en janvier le
deuxième mois le plus rentable après
septembre pour le monde du fitness nous
avons eu la réaction de ces nouveaux
inscrits à la salle de sport plutôt
détox tous les pucks parce qu'une grosse
prise de preuve de plus de poids le
point en soit on l'a on l'a depuis on le
vaincu on essaie d'évacuer c'est un
combat continu avant soit on sort des
repas renée un peu lourd l'a pas trop
envie de se lever
bon on vient quand même ça fait du bien
bah ça fait du bien au moral de voir
qu'on est qu'on est nombreux à être dans
la même entre guillemets galère pour
perdre du poids il ya également la détox
l'idée est simple notre corps ne serait
plus capable de gérer les déchets qui se
seraient accumulés dans notre corps avec
une alimentation considéré comme trop
polluante selon les statistiques un
français prendrait en moyenne entre deux
et trois kilos pendant les fêtes pour
nettoyer son corps il faut donc bannir
les poissons comme le saumon
l'incontournable foie gras les repas à
base de viande ou encore les boissons
alcoolisées et se concentrer plutôt sur
des légumes comme il explique la coach
sportive et diététicienne les ci devra
rouler coûte dans les légumes
on a des fibres et que les fibres
justement ont pour vertu d'accélérer le
système digestif et et en plus c'est
s'assied temps ce que les fibres avec
l'eau prennent du volume dans l'estomac
et on a on est plus vite rassasié et on
arrivera à tenir jusqu'à la fin de la
journée pour prendre un autre repas sans
fringale c'est quand même ce qu'on vise
juste après les fêtes
alors il faudrait entre 2 et 3 semaines
pour détoxifier complètement son corps
mon dieu
c'est votre action c'est trop ouais
c'est long et puis bon football non mais
faut quand même je pense mangé faire
attention aux excès est très bien mais
il faut quand même manger un petit peu
des choses qui nous font plaisir et pas
seulement manger médical ou utile c'est
mon avis on va passer aux de la deuxième
partie du coût en parallèle de ces
anciennes techniques pour perdre du
poids il ya les nouvelles techniques
moins fatigante généralement qui ont vu
le jour ces dernières années dans un
institut de verser les gérants proposé
séance de cryolipolyse ce qui permet de
réduire les graisses par le froid pour
les personnes en excès de poids les
détails avec eric un physique
je pense que c'est pas le moyen de
maigrir à proprement dit je pense que si
vous avez des problèmes de surpoids il
faut d'abord aller voir un
nutritionniste
mais si vous voulez donc ça nous permet
de parfaire des résultats est en tout
cas pas refaire aussi tout ce qui est
morphologiques auquel vous pouvez vous
avez du mal par vous-même même aux plus
mince de votre forme à perdre finalement
qu'il ya des résultats oui après il faut
pas non plus faut pas espérer avoir le
corps qu'on n'a pas ça y'a un moment ils
n'ont leur dis clairement il ya aussi
les fameuses plateformes vibrantes qui
permet de te re quelques minutes de se
muscler selon les statistiques avec un
régime classique on perdrait en 2
semaines 1 25 % de son poids alors qu'on
perdrait près de 11% avec ses
plateformes
ça permettrait de développer la masse
musculaire perte de poids est ce que
vous êtes plus pour les anciennes
méthodes ou les nouvelles méthodes
oui ou non voter ancien en scène sévère
en rouge
séné la nouvelle vous tous une à vous
êtes partagés genre moi je suis au mix
on va faire un petit tour de table pour
fêter ça s'équilibre
les nouvelles c'est surtout que je pense
que si on est un peu voilà moi je suis
partie peu fainéante alors si on est un
petit peu fini ans qu'on n'a pas trop
mais je vais dire si j'en faisais pas
autant je pense que gérer un peu vers
les nouvelles c'est sûr maintenant je
pense que ce qui est vraiment efficace
et plus respectueux du corps c'est bien
manger enfin donc j'ai correctement
faire du sport et dans les anciennes
méthodes pour moi c'est ce qu'il ya de
moins de 2 de mieux et noah moins pire
le coût du sport onebox pas manger non
manger mieux et non manger mieux et
faire des activités voilà avec un coach
pour cible est ce qu'on a besoin de
travailler mais je pense que c'est mieux
hier déjà la première chose que je lui
connais absolument rien cette thématique
je ne sais pas pourquoi on parle de
perte de poids je vois ça du bon sens ne
pas du tout ce dernier mois deux à trois
kilomètres par jour par jour l'ensemble
des fêtes
ça peut être beaucoup plus mais en gros
en gros c'est peu de le dire
dia qu'il faut plutôt privilégier les
anciennes méthodes pour pouvoir éviter
l'effet yoyo parce que là on fonctionne
par excès sur une période festive que ce
soit ils étaient les quatre aliments et
boissons que vous avez cités et qu'il
faut pour ça essayer de viser dans la
durée on est plein de bonnes résolutions
a priori dans les salles de sport en
janvier je pense que les anciennes au
mois de mars
oui apparemment perdu 60% des clients et
ça va bien prétendre l'été voilà l'été
pour septembre pour pouvoir mettre un en
filet un maillot donc en gros ses visées
sur la durée et puis
avoir cette capacité à réguler en fait
sa prise de poids tout en gardant quand
même une partie de plaisir sur sur
l'alimentation et les boissons donc
plutôt méthodes de grand-mère et des
ducks fredec anderson
vous qui êtes un peu le spécialiste
perte de poids kochi morale sur les
anciennes méthodes les nouveaux je suis
surtout sur les méthodes qui marchent
plus que les nouvelles et anciennes
c'est pas trop ça qui m'intéresse c'est
vrai que la santé c'est pas juste une
histoire de deux semaines à la rentrée
après le nouvel an la cryolipolyse en
tout cas ça a l'air de marcher c'est
populaire c'est marketing ça fait
toujours plaisir ça vous promet des
résultats sans aucun effort mais garder
la forme et la santé c'est pas c'est pas
sans effort c'est contraignant c'est pas
marrant de perdre du poids et c'est
compliqué c'est difficile donc c'est
facile de sortir des gros chiffres sur
les doudous des durées courtes parce
qu'on peut toujours être dans l'excès de
restriction pendant deux trois semaines
mais c'est pas durable s'est pas
entretenu
on peut pas entretenir sa santé en se
privant d'un but après erika ça
permettrait de brûler les graisses qu'on
ne peut pas éliminer même en faisant du
sport
ça ne marche pas comme ça ça ne marche
pas comme ça parce que le fonctionnement
des graisses et un système global au
niveau c'est ses conséquences est
compliqué ça se passe au niveau des
hormones ça se passe au niveau du
système nerveux également gestion de la
fin
il faut savoir que quand on perd par
exemple du poids 25% de la masse perdu
c'est de la masse mecs et des muscles et
en fait le problème d'enchaîner les
d'enchaîner les régimes sans jamais
faire de sport c'est qu'à chaque fois on
perd du musc ont perdu mu qu'on remplace
jamais en fait à chaque fois passer ça
l'effet yoyo quoi parce qu'on veut à
chaque fois ont détruit son métabolisme
un petit peu plus et c'est donc dans ce
qu'il faut c'est c'est surveiller son
alimentation si on a quelques kilos à
perdre mange des légumes comme ça a été
dit dans dans les interventions
est-ce que ce que j'aimais dans les
interventions c'est que il rappelle bien
que c'est en plus d'une hygiène de vie
convenable que c'est que c'est
la scène c'est un supplément c'est un
outil en plus c'est pas un outil à la
place de croyez pas qu'il ya une recette
miracle qui va faire le boulot à notre
place
narrant le problème de perdre du poids
c'est qu'on a faim il faut gérer sa fin
et puis il faut apprendre aussi à manger
pour apprendre à manger il faut
apprendre à cuisiner faut c'est pas
facile et c'est vrai que cinq ans c'est
un combat quotidien et c'est vrai que la
santé c'est pas juste une histoire de de
quelques semaines et pour revenir sur
sur les études pendant quand on regarde
les études à plus long terme courant qui
durent au moins un an
on se rend compte que quel que soit le
régime on perdre un ou deux kilos sur
une année alors que c'est encadré par
des scientifiques qui vous fournit ce
qui surveille votre nutrition etc
on perd pas beaucoup on perd on perd
durant la phase de régime et après quand
on revienne alimentation normale d'en
récupérer une partie du du coi qui a été
perdu et c'est vrai que si on avait une
solution n'aurait pas de problèmes
d'obésité à l'heure actuelle on n'aurait
pas ce point de crise sanitaire qu'on
peut voir dans tous les pays développés
donc croire qu'il ya des recettes
miracles et une pilule qui va faire tout
à votre place ça ne marche pas genre si
la caméra qui peut pas de ça et tout ça
tout à l'enseignement des tranchées du
coup ça j'aurais trahi chez moi je moi
j'ai démarré pour tout vous dire je le
match démarre l'année quand et de belles
promesses beaucoup de résolutions
beaucoup des normandes résolution
d'ailleurs j'ai commencé pas un régime
et deux régimes à la fois parce qu'avec
un seul j'avais passé à manger donc oui
on peut se basent ce week-end chez
partie fiscale donc
pour en revenir sérieusement à la perte
de poids je crois que si ces faits aussi
c'est vrai que on le sait tout le monde
fait face à faut que tout le monde fasse
attention à ce qu'on mange à ce qu'on
boit pas d'excès comme monsieur marc
charme pas d'excès pas d'excès faut pas
que ça jusqu'à 106 ans voilà faut pas
abuser faut pas abuser mais après
analyse maintenant six ans je rejoue un
jour jouer mes camarades
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas 36 solutions
il faut un entraînement physique
régulier et après regarder un petit peu
ce qu'on boit est ce qu'on mange
mais les recettes miracles sinon moi si
ça marchait mais je me faisais hiberné
pendant six mois dans un congélateur et
je vais ressortir comme hélène aulas est
impeccable merci et puis quoi et puis
et puis en parlant d'études la deuxième
solution le power plate forme est là pas
la plateforme vibrante
si vous allez voir et voir les quand
même on joue pour ça mais seulement il
ya eu des études de fait comme quoi ce
système de musculation et est très
néfaste présent le cerveau et les
articulations les articulations normes
parce que c'est justement un petit peu
plus un petit peu plus doux que que la
musculation normal mais par contre des
vibrations étaient très très néfaste
pour le cerveau parce qu'on pourrait
reculer les études qui avaient été
faites là dessus donc là aussi je rejoue
alfred ya pas de remettre de remettre de
remède miracle pardon il y aura pas de
remède miracle il faut un entretien
physique régulier et ça c'est la base de
tout son corps il faut pour que il faut
on peut le faire souffrir au pouvoir
après en profiter sinon si on ne fait
pas ces options peuvent en profiter et
les nouvelles technologies finalement
jeu ça peut aussi permettre je sais pas
dans les maisons de retraite aux gens de
faire un peu de sport également dans les
cliniques aussi non mais moi je pense
aussi enfin moi je suis très utilisé en
maison de retraite et dans les cliniques
moi je suis les électrodes je suis pour
les deux méthodes parce que je me dis
aujourd'hui scientifiquement on a avancé
on peut permettre aux gens au niveau
trop mal
tromatik aussi parce que quand on fait
du sport à l'extérieur avec la charge
avec une charge de poids ils chargent de
poids quand on se déplace on se déplace
eh bien c'est traumatisant aussi pour
les articulations quand on est en sur
toi donc je pense que quand on
quand il faut allier les deux il faut
allier de il faut pas rester il faut pas
se dire en prenant une pilule je vais
devenir
je vais devenir comment welt et puis ça
va me suffire non aller à la salle
courir sur un tapis c'est une chose mais
à un moment il faut comme disent les
gens il faut s' il faut aussi se faire
mal il faut faire des efforts sortir à
l'extérieur corée sur la pluie tout ça
mais après ça devient en forge aussi on
se forge mentalement parce que derrière
derrière ça ce qui nous permet aussi de
faire attention à son alimentation
parce que ne ne pas manger c'est c'est
pas naturel c'est pas naturel
donc c'est s'interdire des choses c'est
pas naturel à partir du moment qu'on est
dans un processus de ce2 d'efforts et de
sacrifices pour pour des objectifs
sportifs
on peut l'être aussi pour son corps est
pour pour autre chose mais il faut dire
tu pouvais terminer votre phrase
maintenant il faut pas dire oui la bonne
méthode c'est l'ancienne où c'est là où
c'est la nouvelle fait le tour mettre
des glaçons
le mot de la fin ça que ce thème on
passe maintenant notre rubrique
découverte
un talent yvelinois fait énormément
parler de lui en ce moment sur la toile
son nom louis boniface le very roi de 20
ans totalise plusieurs millions de vues
en faisant de la slackline un sport qui
ressemble au funambulisme créé dans les
années 80 aux etats unis le concept les
sportifs doivent réaliser des figures
sur une sangle élastique tendu une
discipline dans laquelle le prodige de
la verrière excellent il est l'un des
meilleurs européens l'heure actuelle il
me donne les conseils pour être un bon
slackline heures pour être un bon cela
kleiner ya pas de deux choses
particulières qu'il faut avoir parce que
c'est quand même un sport d'équilibré
du coup on travaille énormément la
motricité
on travaille énormément l'iso maîtrise
du corps etc
par contre pour la partie freestyle là
il faut vraiment avoir un corps solide
ils ont une bonne préparation physique
une bonne endurance et un bon repère
dans l'espace voilà pendant une bonne
acrobaties donc c'est une base de
gymnastes trampolinistes ou autre ce
porte il faut pas avoir le vertige
je sais exactement alors ça pour les
personnes qui souhaitent aller au moteur
il faut pas avoir le vertige
là c'est vraiment un combat sur soi même
et voilà l'appréhension du vide elle est
vraiment elle est vraiment présente
lorsque par exemple on est dans les
gorges du verdon ou encore plus près on
le ce soit du côté d'auxerre en faire un
petit tour de table sur ce sport lasri
klein qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
aller là bas pour avoir essayé c'est
quand même bien difficile mais j'ai
essayé
sans parler des figures convaincre on va
même pas jusque là au début rien que
l'équilibré marché et la traversée c'est
déjà difficile donc je n'arrive pas à
envisager de pouvoir faire des figures
naturel c'est extraordinaire moi je
trouve ça extraordinaire france à toute
façon c c'est du cirque là ce niveau là
c'est c'est un athlète un entraînement
sûrement tous les jours on était à dubaï
pour faire des démonstrations
mais non mais ce extraordinaire dans des
séries non mais je suis pas étonné vu le
niveau qu'hier
cl je pense que c'est un alliage
d'énormément de talent il dit qu'il ne
faut pas de particuliers mais entre le
entre le fait d'être sur hawaï et ça
c'est sûr être entre gymnastes être
funambus être un athlète comme dit
hélène et puis justement ce sens de l'
équilibre voire de la chorégraphie parce
que c'est aussi artistique
ça fait quand même pas mal de pas mal de
compétences et pas mal de talent hour on
va regarder la figure qu'il a réalisé
d'ailleurs un triple saut avant regardez
une première mondiale
et il tente de nouvelles figures
également première des premières
mondiales également dans des prochains
hivers entente et de l'art plusieurs
georges qui vous en pensez vous de sa
klein
moi je c'était un mélange et je pense
comme gens comme mon ami c'est un
mélange il faut être bon un bon
équilibre fils un funambule
c'est spectaculaire sa demande
alors après je ne sais pas si ici on
peut considérer que c'est un sport je ne
sais pas parce que là il
ça ça commence il ya tellement de panels
on peut dire c'est plusieurs sports en
un clic
non vraiment révolutionné même chose
pour aujourd'hui ça a l'airé dit
exceptionnellement un peu comme quand
comme tout le monde a dit je pense que
ça demande beaucoup de temps et surtout
beaucoup de travail je suis pas sûr que
ce soit accepté enfin accessible à tous
mais c'est c'est beau et si on a la
possibilité d'en faire ça mérite qu'on
en fait remise à vous je n'ai qu'elle
seulement à vire est impressionnant
impressionnant super ça sera le mot de
la fin
on va terminer par une citation du
joueur de tennis arthur h une des clés
du succès et la confiance en soi une des
clés de la confiance en soi et la
préparation c'est la fin de cette
émission je vous laisse
à bientôt sur tb 78
[Musique]
là